flexon coming off a magnificent start
comes home with the first pitch
and it is skyed out to center field
where taylor trammell roams back
parks underneath it and makes the catch
one pitch one away good start for
flexson
and company flexon has really pitched
well here at home three-and-one at home
with a 1-6-3 era
off to a fast start france handles this
no problem at all
two outs it's a little toothpick coming
off his back crawford
easy play a couple of ground ball outs
right on cue go to the bottom of the
first sean manaya
getting set to take the hill well i
think and you see this 12th start for
sean manaya and
i'd say for him coming into the start
he's got to be thinking about
innings giving some innings trying to
limit the pitch count
so he can go deep in the ball game you
know kaif we always talk about the pitch
count
seems to that magical number that's so
crawford
swings and misses and the first batter
that mania faces
is a strikeout victim say tony working
on his stance hey tony
i'm about ready to call a pitch
wanted to get the field down so both
pitchers good first innings no score
after one
[Music]
is that it is at its best
as this one hops over to kyle seeger
when he throws it with great intent
and is not afraid to have it get hit and
that it's best
when it's thrown to get a swing and to
get put in play
yeah basically i mean what that tells me
is it's for him to try
not to nibble off of the corners with it
it's a pitch that he just needs to throw
with conviction
cut on and missed at 95. good heater
from flexin who
sat down all six faces
what 291 wins that one is
drilled toward left center field kemp
hustling over goes into a slide and
makes a nice catch
tony went into the slide maybe to stop
himself and see what the glove is
glove stays there he goes down the glove
stays up so
it's a question of whether maybe he
didn't see it
as he went into the slide popped up
quickly and then tattoo on his
arm is lou gehrig
so we'll tell you the story about jacob
nottingham when he comes up again
and it's a good start for both starting
pitchers tonight no score
after two
not this time and it is line to left and
that's a hit
fraley over to cut it off he does but
he's got to go into a slide to do it
chapman will go to third he'll stop
there and in the second is elvis andrews
and the a's have second and third
what a great event by elvis anders so
rbi opportunity for
canna and he smokes one to center and
that's a base hit
one run's going to score alva sanders
runs through the stop sign and he's
going to score
mark was holding him up elvis anders
had other ideas to throw was offline
turns out to be a two-run
single and the a's lead to nothing so
here's olson
and that's a base hit to center field
coming in to score is canna
a big two out hit and the a's lead three
to nothing
tremel shading towards left center for
the left-hand power hitting
moreland and that one is hit well
center field and that baby is gone
a very long home run for mitch
morland his fifth of the year how about
444 feet
sounds about right and it's five nothing
the a's lead
crawford taps on to lowry lowry flips to
first and that will do it so the walk
does no damage
and we're headed to inning number four
it's five nothing easily
high out to the gap tremel coasts over
and puts it away to retire the side
taking on sean manaya rubber game of the
series
mitch hanigar leads it off
first pitch and it whistles right off
the lowry's glove and into center field
and a good fastball a little elevated
and he gets his third strikeout so
double play
and a strikeout nothing for the mariners
as we head to the fifth
top of the order marcano
first pitch guide to trimel has been
pretty busy so far
went away
lying into center field
murphy hits the ball hard for the second
time and works and base hit out of it
and that turns around 93 miles an hour
lead off man aboard in front of jacob
nottingham d.h
tonight he hit it hard nottingham going
down swing
like the breaking ball that time so
mixing it up
grounded to lowry a second baseman makes
the easy throw in the mariners to leave
them loaded
through five it's five nothing eights
sean manaya
back to work as he faces henniger
henniger hits it hard nice play by elvis
anders he flips it across the diamond
and they got him
oh man what a play scooped it perfectly
in his glove before hannigan got to the
bag and it's a great play
swings through a fastball and andrews is
out number one
quality fastball at the top of the zone
another long at bat though seven pitches
to put him away he's not happy about it
and he fouls it back 96 that time from
the seven
[Applause]
check swaying and he goes
the savage strikes out the side in order
to
stretch back with the two two comes
mania swinging a miss gets him on the
slider that's five k's now for sean
two and two and back comes manaya swing
and a miss
94 on his what 93rd 94th pitch of the
night
great night for mania sean ready turns
here's the one-two pitch now and that's
on the outside corner
bring him up strike three caught perfect
[ __ ] at first and third
grounds this one's to seeger out at
second the throw to first
not in time cannon beat it out and
that's gonna get himself an rbi
six nothing is one out one on fought
over the ninth and the pitchers are
swinging a ground ball to third chapman
goes to second
camp goes to first double play to end
the game what a great way to end it
and shawn minaya fires a complete game
four hit shutout against the mariners on
this wednesday night
up in seattle